hi everyone this is professor ramdas
science and today i want to talk about
the degeneracies of the isotropic
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator is a simple generalization of
its one-dimensional counterpart the
energy eigenvalues are simply obtained
by adding up the eigenvalues of the
one-dimensional oscillators along the
cartesian directions and the energy
eigenstates are obtained by simply
taking the tensor products between the
energy eigenstates of the
one-dimensional oscillators along the
cartesian directions despite this
apparent simplicity today we're going to
study a really interesting feature that
emerges when this quantum harmonic
oscillator is isotropic which means that
it looks exactly the same in all
directions for an isotropic oscillator
the energy levels become highly
degenerate and this means that there are
many different states that share the
same energy today we're going to explore
how this arises mathematically and we're
also going to visualize what these
energy eigenstates look like so let's go
today we consider a particle moving in
an isotropic three-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator
the discussion builds on the general
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator so if you haven't seen that
video yet i recommend that you check it
out before you continue with this one
as a very quick reminder the hamiltonian
h of a three-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator is given by the
kinetic energy of the particle moving
along the x direction plus the kinetic
energy of the particle moving along the
y direction plus the kinetic energy of
the particle moving along the z
direction
and we also need the potential energy
terms the one along the x direction
along the y direction
and along the z direction
this expression has the full explicit
hamiltonian in the tensor product state
space used to describe the motion of
particles in three spatial dimensions
however we know that when we work with
tensor product state spaces we tend to
simplify our notation by emitting the
various identity operators and tensor
product symbols and in this simpler
notation the hamiltonian h is given by
the three kinetic energy terms
and the three potential energy terms
okay that was a quick intro but
hopefully you should all be familiar
with all of this already
today we're going to consider a special
case of this hamiltonian the isotropic
case
what this means is that we will choose
the frequencies along the different
directions to be equal to each other and
we will collectively call them omega
using the simplified notation we can
very quickly rewrite the hamiltonian
with the same kinetic energy terms
and with the new isotropic potential
energy terms
and we can actually take common factors
to simplify the kinetic energy terms
and we can also take common factors to
simplify the potential energy terms
feel free to pause here for a moment to
convince yourself of these expressions
but everything should be pretty
straightforward
now we've already solved the general
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator up here in the corresponding
video and the solutions to the isotropic
case can be simply taken as special
cases of the general solution so it may
sound a little silly that we should have
a full video looking at this specific
problem
however what we will see today is that
in the isotropic oscillator we have a
particularly nice feature that doesn't
occur in the general case
we have plenty of degeneracies in the
energy spectrum
now before we properly launch into the
isotropic case let's briefly recall the
general eigenvalue equation of the
three-dimensional quantum family
oscillator
using the simplified notation for the
hamiltonian we can regroup the
x-dependent terms
the y-dependent terms
and the z-dependent terms
this here is a hamiltonian of a
one-dimensional quantum phenomenon later
along x
this is also a one-dimensional
oscillator but now along y
and this is also a one-dimensional
oscillator along z
so that the hamiltonian for a particle
in three dimensions is simply the sum of
the hamiltonians of the particle moving
along the three cartesian directions
independently
we can write the eigenvalue equation for
a one-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator in the usual way
where these are the eigenvalues and
these are the eigenstates
and we have one such equation for every
cartesian direction x y and z
and you will also remember that the
eigenvalues are quantized and given by
this expression
where the labels and alpha are
non-negative integers
the eigenvalue equation for the
three-dimensional oscillator is given by
h
acting on the eigenstates which are
given by the tensor product of the
eigenstates of the one-dimensional
oscillators
equal to the energy eigenvalues times
the eigenstates
from the video on the general
three-dimensional quantum harmonics
later we know that the energy
eigenvalues of the three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator are given by
the sum of the energy eigenvalues of a
one-dimensional harmonic oscillator
along the x-direction
factor for one-dimensional oscillator
along the y-direction and the equivalent
term along the z-direction
we can also spell these out explicitly
as the term along x
the term along y
and the term along z
if we now move to the isotropic
oscillator we have that omega x is equal
to omega y which is also equal to omega
z and all are equal to omega
and this means that when we write the
energy
we can take h bar omega as a common
factor and then this multiplies n x plus
and y plus and z plus three halves
we see that for an isotopic oscillator
the energy does not depend on the
individual in x in y and nz but only on
this sum and we can define this sum to
be n
now this implies that we don't need to
label the eigenvalues with all three
indices and x and y and z but instead we
can simply label the eigenvalues with
the single index e n
and they are equal to h bar omega times
n plus three halves
the new collective index n is given by
the sum of the original indices and
remembering that the individual in x and
y and nz are non-negative integers then
this means that n must also be a
non-negative integer
so what does this mean
there are multiple combinations of
values of nx ny and nz that add up to
the same n and therefore give the same
energy
this means that the energy eigenstates
of the isotropic three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator will in
general have some degree of degeneracy
and the aim of this video is to explore
this degeneracy and we will seek to
calculate gn the number of different
states
with the same energy en
but before we launch into the degeneracy
let's briefly look at the eigenfunctions
of the system which will also prove
necessary for our
discussion from the video on the general
three-dimensional quantum pharmacos
later we know that the eigenfunctions
psi and x and y and z of xyz
are simply given by the product of the
eigenfunction of a 1d harmonic
oscillator along x a 1d harmonic
oscillator along y and a 1d harmonic
oscillator along z
as a reminder the eigenfunction of a 1d
harmonic oscillator is equal to a
pre-factor
multiplied by a hermit polynomial
multiplied by a gaussian exponential and
this is true along the x y and z
directions
in these expressions i've already
assumed that we're working with an
isotropic oscillator so the frequency
does not depend on the direction alpha
here here or here
however unlike the energies which only
depend on the sum of nx and y and nz the
eigenfunctions do separately depend on
the index and alpha
and this is the key observation
we're going to find that for every
degenerate energy level we have a family
of distinct eigenfunctions with the same
energy
we're now ready to study degeneracies in
the energy spectrum of the isotropic
oscillator
and the strategy that we will follow
will be to first consider a few examples
and then we will finish with the general
result
so let's start with the ground state n
equals zero
the ground state energy e zero is equal
to three halves h bar omega
how many distinct states have this
energy
to answer this question we need to
consider how many triplets of
non-negative integers n x and y and n z
add up to zero
and there's clearly only one possibility
all of them must be equal to zero
what does this mean this means that the
ground state is non-degenerate so that
the degeneracy of the ground state g
zero is equal to one
we can easily construct the
corresponding wave function which is
simply given by the product of the
ground stage wave functions along x
along y and along z
remembering that the ground state wave
function of the one-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator is simply a gaussian
we can write this full wave function as
equal to this combined prefactor times
this gaussian
we see that this wave function only
depends on the distance from the origin
so it is spherically symmetric
now it is impossible to plot the
eigenfunctions of the three-dimensional
oscillator as we would need a four
dimensional space to do so
however we can visualize them along the
different spatial axis where they
essentially look like they're
one-dimensional counterparts and so this
is what we're going to do
this diagram here shows three slices of
the full ground state wave function of
the isotropic three-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator
the top panel shows the slice along the
x-axis the middle panel is the slice
along the y-axis and the bottom panel
corresponds to the z-axis
we see that we have the ground state for
each of the three one-dimensional
oscillators making up the full
three-dimensional oscillator
each contributes the corresponding
zero-point energy of one-half h-bar
omega
and the three add up to the full zero
point energy of three-halves h-bar omega
of the three-dimensional isotropic
oscillator
let's next consider the first excited
state with n equals one
the energy e1 is equal to five halves h
by omega
so
how many distinct states are such that
nx plus and y plus and z equals one
there are three possible choices for an
x and y and nz
the first is one zero zero and the
corresponding wave function has the
first excited state for the
one-dimensional oscillator along x and
the ground state for the other two
the second choice is zero one zero
and the corresponding wave function had
the ground state along x the first
excited state along y and the ground
state again along zit
and the third choice is 0 0 1 and the
corresponding wave function is given by
the ground state along x and along y and
the first excited state along zit
these three-way functions are different
because the first one has the excited
state along x the second one along y and
the third one along z
however they all lead to the same energy
e1 up here and this means that the first
excited state of the isotropic
three-dimensional quantum moment
oscillator is triply degenerate so that
g1 is equal to three
unlike the simple mathematical form of
the ground state wave function the wave
functions of the excited states have
longer less intuitive expressions so
rather than writing down their explicit
mathematical form we will directly
visualize them
let's visualize the triply degenerate
first excited state
these diagrams again show slices of the
full first excited state wave function
this particular example corresponds to
the case where the extra quantum of
energy is added along the x direction so
that the total energy contribution from
this direction is three halves h bar
omega while the system is in the ground
state along the y contributing one half
h bar omega
and along the z direction also
contributing one half h bar omega
their combined contribution adds up to
five halves h bar omega the total energy
of the first excited state of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator
this second example shows a distinct
first excited state in which the
excitation is along the y-direction
contributing through half h by omega
the x direction contributes the zero
point energy and the z direction also
contributes the zero point energy
despite a different distribution of the
overall energy that combined
distribution again adds up to five
halves h bar omega
and you can now see how this will work
in the third distinct first excited
state the additional energy quantum in
this case is along the z direction in
the bottom panel
right so putting everything together
what these diagrams show is that to get
to the first excited state of the
three-dimensional isotropic oscillator
we essentially need to add one quantum
of energy to one of the individual
harmonic oscillators along one of the
spatial dimensions
it doesn't really matter which one we
excite because the oscillator is
isotropic so excitations along any
direction will provide the same energy
we have three different possibilities
with the extra quantum of energy along
the x
the y
or the z directions
and these three possibilities give a
triply degenerate first excited state
let's now consider the second excited
state with n equals two
the energy e2 is equal to seven halves h
bar omega
so how many distinct states are such
that nx plus and y plus and z equals two
there are six possibilities now for this
triplet
the first three distinct states are
simple extensions of what we already
discussed for the first excited state
they are 2 0 0 with this associated wave
function which is given by this product
then we have 0 2 0 and the corresponding
wave function given by this product
and we also have 0 0 2
with the corresponding wave function
given by this other product
now this situation is essentially
equivalent to the one that we had for
the first excited state in the sense
that the excitation is along one
direction only and it can be a long x y
was it and the only difference is that
we're now adding two quanta of energy
but we have another three possibilities
because we can also have the two extra
quantity of energy spread across
different directions
we can have 1 1 0 with this associated
wave function given by this product
1 0 1 with this associated wave function
given by this product
and 0 1 1 with this associated wave
function and given by this other product
this situation is qualitatively
different as now there is an excitation
along two different directions in the
first case along x and y in the second
along x and z and in the third along y
and z
all of these lead to the same energy e2
up here
and this means that the second excited
state of the isotropic three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator is six-fold
degenerate so that g2 is equal to six
let's visualize the six-fold degenerate
second excited state with the usual
diagrams
the first column corresponds to the case
where the system reaches the second
excited state by adding two quanta of
energy along the x direction
the second column shows the distinct
excited stage in which the two quanta of
energy are added along the y direction
and the third column is the same thing
but for the z direction
as we've discussed these three cases are
a simple extension of what we had in the
first exclusive state with the two extra
quantity of energy being added along one
of the three spatial dimensions and it
doesn't really matter which one it is
because the system is isotropic
but we now have three more possibilities
the fourth column shows the case when we
add one extra quantum of energy along x
and one extra quantum along y
the fifth column adds one quantum along
x
and one long zit
and the sixth column adds one quantum
along y
and one along z
in this second group of three states the
two quanta that we need to add to the
system are shared between two spatial
dimensions
so why do we have so many possibilities
this is actually not a general result
for any three-dimensional system
it is a special feature of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
the key is that the energy eigenvalues
of the quantum harmonic oscillator are
equally spaced the energy quantum is
always h bar omega between any two
levels
this means that we can add the exact
same energy by adding two quanta along
some particular direction like we do in
the first three cases or by adding two
quanta along two different directions as
we do in these other three cases
so let's finish by generalizing these
results
what is the degeneracy of a general
energy eigenvalue e n
we need to figure out how many triplets
n x and y and n z are such that their
sum is equal to n
to figure it out let's first fix n x
then n y plus and z must be equal to n
minus nx
how many choices do we have for ny and
nz
the first is that ny is zero and then nz
must be n minus nx
the second is that ny is one and then nz
must be n minus nx minus one and so on
all the way to ny being n minus nx and
nz being zero
if we consider all of these
possibilities we get a total of n minus
nx plus one terms
this means that the degeneracy gn of
state n is given by the sum over all
possible choices of an x and we've just
figured out that for every such choice
we have n minus nx plus one terms as
possible choices of n y and then z
n and one can be taken out of the sum so
we end up with this term
minus the sum over an x
this is just n plus one
and this is a standard arithmetic series
which is equal to this
putting everything together we end up
with one half times n plus one times n
plus two
and this is our big result the energy
eigenvalue e n of the isotropic three
dimensional quantum harmonic oscillator
has degeneracy one half times n plus one
times n plus two
you should convince yourself that this
general result is really consistent with
the three examples that we've discussed
but more generally we see that the
higher the energy level the larger the
degeneracy this again arises from the
fact that the energy levels in a
harmonic oscillator are equally spaced
and that in the isotropic oscillator the
spacing is the same in all three spatial
dimensions
now conceptually the higher the energy
the more ways we can distribute it
amongst the three directions
i want to finish with two brief points
first there are some very interesting
underlying symmetries that lead to
degeneracies of the isotropic quantum
harmonic oscillator that we've explored
today and we may get into that in a
future video
second as the energy eigenvalues are
degenerate this means that the
corresponding eigenstates are not
uniquely defined
it is actually interesting to explore
alternative choices for the energy
eigenstates and we describe a different
approach to the isotropic
three-dimensional harmonic oscillator in
the context of central potentials so i
encourage you to check out those
videos the isotropic three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator has a highly
degenerate energy spectrum among other
things what this means is that there
isn't a unique choice for the energy
eigenstates in any given degenerate
subspace in fact in our videos we find
isotropic harmonic oscillators in a
different context as well when we study
central potentials i therefore really
encourage you to check out those videos
as well because there we write down the
energy eigenstates in a completely
different way and as always if you liked
the video please subscribe